you're playing tyrion lanister on Game
of Thrones Game of Thrones is wrapped
right that's totally wrapped at this
point yes okay so I know you can't tell
me anything about what happens in the
season I'm not gonna put you on the spot
but a little bit I'll be all clever and
coy with my answers and frustrate all of
you but happy ending right it's all
happiest if you think this has a happy
ending
he who hasn't been paying attention you
say please again hey everybody its
charlie we got new Game of Thrones
Season eight to talk about I also have a
trailer for the new book that they're
releasing in November that I'll play
later in the video but the season 8
stuff first do you just love the heavy
sarcasm and all the actors voices when
they're asked about getting a happy
ending to season 8 oh you know of course
that's what the story is all about Game
of Thrones happy endings everybody gets
exactly what they want
so Peter Dinklage did a whole bunch of
other interviews because of a new HBO
special that he did dropping a whole
bunch of details about season 8 there's
also some really cool Ned Stark Sean
Bean news 2 so we'll break it down
there's a new round of that fire and
blood book giveaway it's coming out in
November all you have to do to enter
that is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on the video Peter Dinklage had
a little bit of fun on Colbert talking
about his HBO special my dinner with
herb a but he did talk to a couple
different publications giving some
better quotes so first one is about
Tyrians trajectory his arc through the
series in Peter Dinklage says he
certainly developed a deeper sense of
responsibility over the course of the
show he was a pretty irresponsible
character to begin with he used his
position as the outcast of the family
like an adolescent would he pushed in in
all their faces talking about the other
Lannisters the beauty of Tyrion is that
he grew out of that mode in a couple of
seasons and developed a strong sense of
responsibility not morality because he
always had that but what to do with his
intelligence there's a whole lot more to
unpack and the next answer that he gave
were the publication as without giving
anything away how do you feel about
where Tyrion is a left at the end of the
series he says I feel very very bit of a
pause I'm trying to find the right word
I think he would
given a very good conclusion no matter
what that is death can be a great way
out and that probably sounds like one of
the most ominous things that any of the
cast members have said about their
characters going into the final season
the other actors have been doing a lot
of interviews mostly praising the
scripts and how the series does a good
job of bookending itself and making it
sound like it's gonna be a little bit
different from what George our Martin
might have in mind for the end of dream
of spring but if Tyrion really is gonna
die there's really only a couple of ways
I think that goes down because they're
saying that everybody regardless of what
their ending is whether they live or die
get very fitting appropriate endings to
the characters arcs so for example
Tyrion is not a warrior so it's not like
he would die trying to stab the knight
King it sound like he's gonna be running
around in battle there was that
hilarious scene with him trying to put
armor on running into battle and getting
knocked out as they all ran in and
missing the entire battle that's a very
Tyrion Lannister kind of moment battle
planning giving rousing speeches that's
what his character does say like during
the upcoming Battle of Winterfell
against the night king during season
eight he'd be someone to stand on the
battlements with Samwell and bran while
everybody else like Jon Snow Daenerys
and her dragons ride into battle if
we're talking about endings that are
appropriate for the characters arc
during the series usually the things
that get him into trouble during the
series are wine women in his emotions
letting his emotions get the better of
him so he makes really bad judgment
calls they cause him bigger problems
later on
like with Shae so there was an
interesting interview that he did a
while ago where he tried to clarify
what's going on between Jon Daenerys and
Tyrion in this moment here because even
though they care about each other think
about the families that they come from
he doesn't know anything about Jon being
a secret Targaryen so that's only gonna
compound things and it's gonna cause a
lot of problems when they get back to
Winterfell more recently he gave a
different interview in the past couple
of months where he said that he actually
thinks that Tyrion does have romantic
feelings for Daenerys and there is some
jealousy in play so you may have seen a
lot of people theorizing recently the
Tyrion will be the one to betray
Daenerys because of all this stuff
that's going on and she will pull a Robb
Stark Karstark moment where she executes
him and that will be the end of the
character there haven't been any confer
about that but there are certain moments
that they do like to repeat on Game of
Thrones where people make the same
mistakes like it would be a mistake to
execute Tyrion so we think whether or
not you believe theories like that
depends on whether or not you feel like
that's a justified ending for the
character and it's obviously one of many
different theories let me know in the
comments below though do you actually
think the Tyrians cleverness will get
the better of him during season eight
and that will lead to his demise
not so much in actual physical conflict
with someone else but his own tongue
getting him in trouble because george RR
martin has said that before Tyrians
tongue is always getting him in trouble
Korean just talks and his tongue is
always getting him into trouble
so his weapons are wit and sarcasm and
you know scathing observances and
truth-telling remember what happened way
back when Robb Stark killed Lord
Karstark later that led to Lord
Karstarks surviving son siding with
Ramsay Bolton against the Starks heading
into the Battle of the bastards
so if history really is going to repeat
itself in that way then if Daenerys got
rid of Tyrion then that could lead to
another scenario where you have
Lannisters versus Starks by the end of
the series because there is gonna be
some second big battle happening at
King's Landing but without really
knowing what the alliances are going to
be like heading into those final
episodes we don't have an idea for what
that battle is going to be over if it's
just gonna be purely them getting rid of
Cersei because she's gone completely mad
or if it's gonna be caused by some
emotional turns that lead to the
dissolution of their existing alliances
right now you may have also heard the
news about a special Game of Thrones
episode that they filmed with all the
old cast members coming back Sean Bean
was doing an interview for something
totally different naturally the
interviewers asked him about the Game of
Thrones prequels and season aid and his
thoughts about everything and he
revealed the Dan and Dave brought all
the big major cast members back going
back to season one all the dead
characters to shoot a special episode
for the final season they didn't say
exactly what they were doing it sounds
more like a documentary-style
retrospective where they all sit around
and talk about their characters and how
they feel like everything played out
nobody seems to know when HBO is going
to drop it if it'll be before the series
or if they'll wait till after the finale
but because they'll be
talking about the entire series it's
implied that those people that came back
know what the ending is so they'll be
talking about that
meaning the HBO would have to wait till
after the finale to Aaron the trades
were also asking Sean Bean about whether
or not he would want his character to
pop up during the prequel TV series that
they're developing and we already know
that they're not doing Robert's
rebellion so there's really no way to
include him there been a few rumors
about them casting for the prequel
series they're shooting that in February
so I would say by the end of the year
we'll have a pretty good idea of who's
going to be starring in it because HBO
typically announces when they cast
people especially really big actors they
just did the watchmen pilot earlier this
year they let us know who all the actors
were that we're starring in that without
letting us know which characters they
were playing so if they want to be
really mysterious about it they might
also do the same thing for the Game of
Thrones prequel where they just tell us
who the actors are without telling us
who their characters are but if they can
finish filming that fast enough that we
might get a cobbled together teaser for
it by the Game of Thrones finale like
they might air the finale and then air a
teaser for the prequel series so we'll
hear more about that next year no
worries george RR martin also dropped a
trailer for the fire and blood book but
because people are kind of upset about
it not being winds of winter and i think
everybody understands what fire and
blood is about i'll just not include it
in this and we'll talk about it when the
book drops is this any really cool stuff
leave all your Game of Thrones video
requests in the comments below
congratulations Smith tag you're the
giveaway winner from my last big video
please email me on the about page of my
channel so I can get your contact
details click here to learn all about
the dire wolves during season 8 and
click here torn about the early season 8
premiere date thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight